hi everyone i am
currently a third year undergraduate
biomedical sciences and research student
today i will be presenting my poster on
gene expression meta-analysis of
colorectal cancer tumor cells which
reveals genes which are associated in
the process of tumorogenesis so to start
with introduction this is a study in
which we wanted to find out that are
there any specific gene signatures that
are associated with colorectal cancer
diseases the colorectal cancer is very
deadly and approximately 12 million
people are diagnosed every year with
colorectal cancer so in this
experiment of this study we in order to
find out the gene signatures and we
selected a few data sets that had
samples of colorectal cancer versus
normal samples and by using those data
sets we elucidated 13 gene signatures
now the data sets were divided into
three types and they were used for the
following things first is gene
identification second is gene
verification and third is gene
comparison for gene identification we
use the two data sets which are
mentioned over here in the method
section
after using those two test cells we got
a
gene signature now those gene signature
could be uh
data set a
as a reference versus set data set b as
a query and vice versa that is set data
set b as a query versus set data set a
as a reference so by using this we
derived the gene signatures and whatever
um
genes fell in this category were the
gene panels that we used to identify
genes in the other data sets now these
gene panels had 77 genes in the positive
panel and 55 genes in the negative panel
and then we compared and verified this
among the other random models now these
random models were used to exactly find
out that are these genes only specific
in humans or other also founded other
kinds of um colorectal cancers like
polyp tumors and hyperlepsia and further
on so out of this
out of like 55 genes that are present in
the positive colorectal cancer gene
panel 54 of them were continuously
showed verified and present in the gene
signatures of other glandular tumors and
so there is 77 genes that were present
in the negative gene panel out of which
75 were constant throughout the
other gene signatures that were
identified and they had p-value less
than 0.01 and less than 0.05 so this
showed that our statistical significance
of the shared genes is must and hence we
went ahead and confirmed the gene
comparison by comparing it with the
random model magnification or verifying
in other patients that had another kinds
of samples so what do we conclude from
our study so this is usually a
bioinformatics study that is mrna
microarray data analysis which predicts
the genes that are potentially involved
in developing crc tumors examining gene
signatures we found 54 overexpressed
genes that most important were solid
family carrier genes calcium genes and
amongst them was the most prevalent
solid carrier family genes now these
genes were highly overexpressed and
shows that their association with tumor
genes is in the process of colorectal
cancer not only this but a lack of
experimental evidence and dry lab
experiences show that how much more work
is needed for you know actually working
in the area of colorectal cancer and
gene therapy and genes images however to
verify this work we need certain kinds
of
experiments which you know stand as a
proof that the verified genes and the
gene signatures are actually standing
out in patients of colorectal cancer
in over here in the diagram of the
conclusions you can finally see that
what i have concluded that is out of the
55 change from the positive crc parents
54 of them were constant which shows how
apt and accurate our results were
similarly for negative panel out of 77
gene 75 of them were uniform throughout
the signature however if the desired
outcome is prioritized of the potential
gene signatures that have been
identified in further laboratory or
clinical elimination the gse based
approach would be very very useful thank
you so much